Democrats keep saying the quiet part out
loud all week they have been
inadvertently admitting their intentions
by crying over Elon musk's Free Speech
Pledge on Twitter
they've admitted to censoring
conservatives which they had previously
denied but they're admitting that
because they're complaining about Elon
Musk changing it by criticizing the
power that Elon Musk could wield if he
succeeds at taking over Twitter they are
admitting to possessing and really and
wielding that power themselves for years
which they denied for years but which
they have done against conservatives
and now by attacking curriculum
transparency bills in schools they are
admitting to teaching our kids all sorts
of creepy stuff that they know we'd
object to that's the only reason to
oppose curriculum transparency is
because the thing that they denied that
we've been accusing them of doing is
obviously true Biden of course is still
taking the side of the teacher unions
and the radical administrators he is
lamenting why why oh why are
conservatives making a political issue
out of what teachers are teaching
American teachers
have dedicated their lives to teaching
our children lifting them up we had to
stop making the target of the culture
wars
just a reminder that conservatives are
not the ones who started the culture
wars by definition conservatives are
perfectly fine with the culture the way
our culture has traditionally been it is
the libs the leftists the progressives
the radicals they are the ones who by
definition do not like that traditional
culture and want to change it it is the
leftists who are the aggressors in the
culture war and they waged that culture
War especially in schools so why might
conservatives be focusing on radical
teachers Biden answers his own question
you've heard me say it many times
about our children but it's true they're
all our children
and the the reason you're the teachers
of the year is because you recognize
that
they're not somebody else's children
they're like yours when they're in the
classroom
they're not somebody else's your
children don't belong to you Biden says
your children belong to the teachers one
that statement is horrifying and the
best argument for homeschooling I've
ever heard but two in practice
very often that is true if you're
leaving your kids with these teachers
all day some of whom are extreme
political radicals they are effectively
raising your kids which is why it's all
the more important to take back control
of the curricula that radical activists
are using to poison our kids Minds at
schools
it's been a great week for conservatives
for the first time in years we've at
least felt that we're taking back some
political power but the establishment is
not going to give up that easy they've
already got plans to make up for
whatever power they might have lost on
Twitter
in the schools in the government and in
your wallet I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Isaac
kessinger who says you mean we've
circled back to blood magic how lovely
this never goes wrong referring I
suppose to Megan Fox and Machine Gun
Kelly who drink each other's blood and
perform all sorts of occult rituals yeah
just a reminder that there is nothing
new Under the Sun every idea that we
have that we think is super new and
modern and wow it's a brand new
discovery it's not whether it's
transgenderism whether it's the new push
among the elites to live forever and to
conquer death whether it's people doing
weird blood rituals to try to to expand
their Universe man and take control of
the created world all of those things
have been done for thousands and
thousands of years usually by extremely
well Always by extremely misguided
people and usually by idiots and it's
it's our modern Elites who think they're
Geniuses for discovering something that
goes back to the dawn of time when you
want the best people around you working
for your company doing the jobs you need
done I strongly recommend you check out
ZipRecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
Knowles you know I think it's really
important to keep learning new skills
all the time not just when you're a
little kid in school but all the time
that is how you grow you've got to keep
learning new skills
like Zip recruiter sip recruiter is
always learning new skills their AI is
always learning so if you're hiring
their AI gets better and faster at
finding the right candidates for all of
your roles and right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com Knowles
ZipRecruiter uses powerful matching
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then it's
not just spaghetti at the wall it
proactively presents those candidates to
you you review those recommended
candidates then you can invite your top
choices to apply for the job that
encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the U.S based on G2
ratings right now you can try
ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com Knowles that's
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ZipRecruiter the smartest
way to hire
Joe Biden's going back to that old
Democrat well of flattering teachers
trying to beef up his support among the
teacher unions and then at a deeper
level trying to use the schools to push
their radical agenda long term nothing
new about this the Dems have been doing
it for 50 60 years now at least and
really it goes back much earlier goes
back to the earliest days of the public
school movement in America it has always
had a decidedly intentionally
Progressive bent to it and what the Dems
do
is they accuse their opponents
of doing what they themselves have done
and you hear this especially with one of
the stupidest Democrat talking points on
education which is that Republicans are
a great threat to education because they
want to ban books
today there are too many politicians
trying to score political points trying
to ban books even math books I mean do
you ever think even the younger teachers
you ever think would you be teaching you
and be worrying about book burnings and
banning books
all because it doesn't fit somebody's
political agenda you ever imagine that
isn't that so crazy uh I could imagine
that here's how I would imagine that I'd
imagine that I were a teacher and I
wanted to teach anything from the Bible
in class the Bible the most important
book ever written from which even if
you're not a Believer surely you have to
admit all of Western literature the the
Western tradition Springs out of the
Bible it's the most important book ever
written you're not allowed to teach that
in schools that's that is a Banned Book
and it wasn't conservatives who banned
that book it was liberals who banned
that book
it is true Republicans and conservatives
want to ban certain books we want to ban
BDSM weird gay LGBT porn from elementary
schools that's what we're doing I'm not
being hyperbolic here there is actual
outright purely obscene prurient creepy
sex porn in school libraries and and
even sometimes these things leak into
the assigned material not just in
college or high school or even middle
school but all the way down to
elementary schools that's happening
right now and so yes people want to ban
that in terms of the books that
conservatives want to ban in the
classroom we want we don't want to ban
math books we want to ban books that use
math and other subjects as a way to push
a radical and false racial and sexual
agenda critical race Theory
transgenderism and and all the rest of
the radical left's agenda we want to ban
that because instead of students reading
those bad and stupid books that will
harm their education we want them to
read good books that will actually
educate them just like if if you had a
math textbook that we're teaching that
two plus two equals five everyone every
sensible person would want to ban that
book from the classroom because that's
harming students education and you've
only got so much time
you've only got so many books that you
can read in the classroom and if you
teach that one thing is true then you
are implicitly teaching that the
opposite of that thing is not true so if
you're teaching that two plus two equals
five you are implicitly teaching that
two plus two does not equal four but two
plus two does equal four and so that's
what you want to teach in the classroom
and so we're Banning books that peddle
falsehoods and destructive perverse
ideologies and instead we want to
replace them with good books that will
be edifying the left has been doing the
same thing for years they just do it in
reverse they replace books that are true
tell you the true story about history
that present good literature that
present accurate math that is that is
not totally surrounded by crazy leftist
theories they've replaced all of those
good books with their nonsense up to and
including pornography
so yeah it's just a debate over
standards and yes just like just like
you Libs kick to the Bible out of
schools we want to kick gay porn out of
the second red classroom so okay I guess
there's no disputing taste I suppose but
as far as I'm concerned I I would rather
students be taught things that are good
and true and beautiful and not a bunch
of obscene weird stuff could you ever
imagine
of course they could imagine they're the
ones who did it in the first place
now what what is being taught in schools
I every time I mention this the libs
come out and they say I'm a conspiracy
theorist and none of these obscene
materials are actually being taught in
schools okay if that's the case why is
Rhode Island right now trying to
enshrine the right of Educators to teach
sexual pleasure courses in schools there
there's legislation before the Rhode
Island legislature Senate Bill 2285
that would amend current law so that
what they deem to be culturally
appropriate courses in family life or
sex education can be taught to Children
beginning in the sixth grade so this is
when students are 11 years old
what kind of teachings quote
I'm just reading directly from the bill
here teachings would recognize
pleasure-based sexual relations
different sexual orientations and be
inclusive of same-sex relationship the
ACT would also provide that instruction
include gender gender expression gender
identity in the harm of negative gender
stereotypes
the creepiest part of course is are
these two words pleasure based why are
you talking to 11 year olds about
pleasure-based sexual relations that's
extremely weird well there's an answer
to this and the answer is going to upset
Republicans who don't want to be called
transphobic or homophobic or any other
kind of phobic that the sort of
Republicans who who want to claim that
the Lo the educational on Florida has
nothing to do with LGBT has nothing to
do with don't say gay it could just be
called the don't say straight Bill too
because it just bands talk about sex
entirely no the the issue here is LGBT
it is LGBT and and that's not to say we
need to be mean to people who have
different sexual desires or anything
like that but it is to say that we need
to be clear about the issue the reason
that this bill is being pushed in Rhode
Island
is because
there is inevitably some kind of sexual
education that goes on in schools when
you read a little book to your
kindergarten or first grade class where
there's a mommy and a daddy and a baby
you are implicitly teaching something
about sex sexual relations and the
family
that's why no conservative has a problem
if you if you read the book to the class
about Mama Bear and daddy bear and baby
bear but we would have a problem if you
read a book about Mama Bear and leather
daddy bear and leather daddy bear as
boyfriends polyamorous you know Harem or
something like that we wouldn't support
that even though they're they're both
just teaching implicit lessons about sex
and family but one is disordered and one
is perfectly traditional and normal
the reason they have to say pleasure
based sexual relations is because
traditionally when we talk about sex we
talk about sex as though it has a
purpose
that things in life have purpose the
purpose of the leftist tears Tumblr is
to give me my leftist ears so I can
drink them up the purpose of this
microphone is to record my voice when
I'm doing my show and bring it to all of
you and the purpose of sex is to have
babies the purpose of sex is to create
new life to join together two people man
and woman to come together in a
complementary
fashion and then out of those two people
and their love together to create a new
life now there are all sorts of
different ways that you can use your
sexual faculties and uh some of those
involve a man and a woman some of those
involve you know
three dudes and a billy goat some of
those involve just yourself as Woody
Allen called it sex with someone you
love but the purpose of those things is
obviously not procreation the purpose of
those would merely be pleasure so sex
when it fulfills its purpose of openness
to life pleasure is a byproduct of that
very often one hopes that that's a
byproduct of that but when you make
pleasure the end goal of that you've put
the cart before the horse that it has
never been taught in the traditional
sexual education such as it is that the
purpose of sex is pleasure it's a nice
nice aspect of sex but it's not the
purpose if you want to be able to teach
lgbtq ideology you've got to make
pleasure at the end so you've got to
completely invert the teaching about sex
these Democrats are not idiots they're
very sophisticated they know what
they're doing and Republicans I fear
have no idea what they're doing when you
want to learn a thing or two you've got
to check out
Prager you you know how much I love
prageru I host a show on prageru I do
videos on fragru I've written for
prageru and
one new project that prageru has
launched is prageru kids just the other
night just the other night I was sitting
reading good night books to sweet little
buddy my little baby boy and he hands me
the prageru kids book Autos tales and so
I read it it's about this little Dennis
and his little dog and they go on all
these historical adventures and they
clear up all the crap that your kids are
being fed in schools and all the woke
materials and they tell you great
wonderful kids stories about history
about the way the world really works so
great I sometimes do it in my Dennis
Prager voice well now little buddy so
prageru kids has created nearly 150
pieces of video and print content for
children in kindergarten through 12th
grade they've got animated shows
Illustrated books digital magazines
prageru kids offers entertaining and
educational content to equip families to
save the future of America
300 000 parents teachers and
grandparents and caregivers have already
subscribed to prageru kids.com do it
you'll get new stuff in your inbox every
week for free I absolutely love it you
got to do it right now
prageryoukids.com head on over there
today
speaking of sexual education for kids
you know my colleague Matt Walsh Matt is
a beloved women's studies scholar he is
the leading uh lgbtq plus children's
author in the country
and Amazon is very upset about this
Amazon we knew this months ago
Amazon had been trying to suppress
Matt's book Johnny the walrus
a story about a confused little boy who
thinks that he's a walrus and whose
Society encourages him to believe that
he's a walrus
so the book did very very well when it
first came out but Amazon tried to
suppress it and as always when the libs
go in and they get exposed trying to
suppress something it skyrockets to the
top of the chart so I think for for a
little while yesterday Matt actually had
two best-selling books on the charts
it's his upcoming book but it's a woman
and then the the children's book that
actually came out a while ago a a
whistleblower at Amazon leaked the
footage of Amazon conspiring to suppress
Johnny the walrus
it's been a very traumatic experience
for transgender amazonians and our
transgender customers Johnny The Walrus
is a bit of a problematic book uh not a
bit it is
it is not a bit of a problem it's one
hell of a problem you are selling a
manual now to teach kids to bully other
kids to commit suicide
I talked to she said she was going to
get the book
ripped off of your site now he is
bragging that he has the number one book
you are still going to continue to sell
it and now he's bragging and that he's
glad it's going to make the lgbtqia
kids especially transgenders
commit suicide
so because Matt Walsh said that little
boys can't become walruses
lgbtq kids
even that whole concept is extremely
problematic the idea that five-year-olds
have this distinct sexual identity
even moving past that for a second the
idea is that because Matt Walsh made a
book about how a little kid can't become
a walrus that now kids are going to
commit suicide because of him and
Amazon's taking this lunatic woman
seriously saying yes you're oh wow
that's so we have to do something we
need to try to suppress Matt one way or
the other and of course when this comes
out what happens the people want to buy
this book
the book was very popular
the idea is very popular look look what
happened at Twitter
when Elon Musk came in and said we are
going to have free speech at that
platform
something changed overnight I've gained
something like 70 000 Twitter followers
in the last four days three or four days
other people are some some other people
are reporting even larger gains is it
just Bots I don't think it's just Bots
because a lot of these new followers or
blue check marks or people who are
supposedly verified getting a lot more
engagement something changed in the way
that Twitter is working to allow
conservatives overnight to have a lot
more engagement have a much wider reach
on the platform it would seem to me that
that is a an easing up on the
suppression of conservatives
despite the best efforts efforts of the
liberal sensors
people still know some basic truths we
know that men are not women we know I
think we know that babies are babies we
know basic facts of of reality even
covet that was one of the great examples
of censorship you weren't allowed to say
certain things about covid now you might
be able to on Twitter but on on the
other social platforms including the
platforms that this show airs on you're
still not allowed to say things about
Twitter or you're still not allowed to
say a lot of things about covid and the
vaccine you are not permitted even today
you are not permitted to say that the
vaccine does not work
the vaccines there are multiple you're
not allowed to say that they don't work
so I'm not if I made that declarative
statement right now that the vaccines
don't work I would be censored you would
not hear it in this show
even though
the vaccine here's what people say this
is what people say because the vaccines
do not prevent
Contracting the virus or transmitting
the virus as we were told that they
would by Joe Biden and Dr fauci and
Rachelle wolenski now what people say to
try to split the baby is they say well
the vaccines are yes so they may not
prevent you from Contracting or
transmitting the virus but they're very
very good at stopping hospitalization
and death which may or may not be true
I'm not sure if that's true or not the
only reason I have to believe that is
because of the people who have been
lying to me for two years and and the
people who were
very publicly wrong about what the
vaccines would do in the first place
they insist that they do that so maybe
they do that okay fine I'll keep an open
mind
but
in order for a thing to work
in order for a thing to work the thing
has to accomplish its purpose it kind of
gets back to our discussion of sex a
little bit earlier
things have a purpose the leftist tears
tumbler has a purpose to give me my
leftist ears the microphone has a
purpose to broadcast my voice
the the purpose of vaccines we were told
by Biden by wolenski by Dr fauci but is
to stop people from getting a virus and
transmitting a virus so if the vaccines
don't do that then
well I'm not allowed I'm not allowed to
finish that sentence I guess if the
the gun is to shoot bullets
the purpose of a gun is to shoot bullets
if the gun doesn't shoot bullets the gun
cannot be said to work the gun May
coincidentally make a really good
paperweight
but even though the gun makes a good
paperweight if it doesn't shoot bullets
you can't say the Gun Works
no well it's a very it's very highly
effective at being a paperweight okay
but what was the purpose of the gun does
it work so you're not allowed you are
not allowed to make the statement the
vaccines don't work and I use this as an
example because it's something
it's something where everybody knows
that the vaccines don't do the thing
that
fauci and wolensky and Biden said that
they would do and that vaccines just as
a category of thing
are supposed to do and we all know
everybody knows that even the libs agree
we all agree with that and yet we're not
allowed to say it and that drives people
crazy that is the kind of censorship
that we are seeing throughout our
culture and so when Elon Musk even sort
of Intimates that we might ease off that
a little bit everyone can breathe
a sigh of relief everyone can breathe a
little more freely why are parents
showing up to the school boards why did
Glenn Younkin win in Virginia why is
Rhonda Santos having the time of his
life in Florida right now
why it's because of these individual
issues education transgenderism critical
race Theory the covet lockdowns it's
because of these but more it's because
this corrupt ruling class is just
forcing us to lie all the time and it
drives us up a wall and it's so
disrespectful and it's so insulting and
it feels as tyrannical as any sort of
condition of government could be when
you're not even permitted to be honest
when you're not even permitted to be
honest in your private conversations in
in messages on social media platforms to
one another
that is what's driving people up a wall
and the libs have their story and
they're sticking to it
they're not changing anything
Biden can't come clean on any of these
issues he's underwater on all of them
and so now because he's desperate for
the Democrats to win
in the 2022 midterms and then in 2024
he's just trying to give out freebies
right now Biden is is intimating that
he's willing to postpone or just
outright cancel student debt Biden said
during a private meeting with Democrats
this is according to widespread reports
that he's open to canceling student loan
debt even though he didn't really focus
on that issue during the first year of
his presidency he thinks that'll be a
good freebie why is he doing that
he's doing it to reward his base
his base of
college educated idiots his base of
teacher Union Thugs and to create
incentives for more people to go through
these institutions that turn turn out
more liberals that turn out more
Democrats and because he's got the power
he's willing to exercise the power I
forget who it was yesterday I someone
made this comment this is not an
original thought of my own
that the party that does something is
always going to beat the party that just
wants to be left alone
for a long time conservatives just said
we just want to be left alone just do
whatever you want
use whatever bathroom you want don't do
what do whatever you want in your
community in your state and just please
just leave me alone you can redefine
marriage you can redefine just do
whatever you want in your schools just
leave me alone that's never going to
work
the the political Community has to set
standards we have to say we have to make
laws we have to we have to just
set certain parameters that will
describe how we live and so the party
that has a vision for that and that is
actually going to wield political power
to implement that they're going to be
the guys who win and the rest of us who
throw our hands in the air and bury our
heads in the sand we're going to lose
that's inevitable
when the when the culture begins to
reflect everything other than our own
beliefs it's time to build our own which
is what we're doing the daily wire is
taking on Hollywood we're taking on
razor companies that cave to the woke
we're taking on the publishing industry
we're taking on the probably biggest
entertainment company from all of our
childhoods Disney
because it's about time we do something
so you can too stop giving money to
organizations that hate your guts help
us build Alternatives where the left is
destroying the foundations of our
society start today head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe where new
members can use code Knowles Canada
w-les for 20 off your membership head on
over right now if you want to do
something if you actually if you if you
don't just want to complain and lament
and whine and say oh no the sky is
falling which it very well might be if
you want to take a proactive step put
your money where your math is well head
on over to dailywire.com subscribe use
code Knowles for 20 off your membership
we'll be right back with a lot more
you didn't think that the left was going
to take the Elon Musk takeover of
Twitter lying down did you you didn't
think they were saying okay we lost we
lost Twitter
so we tried to censor conservatives we
tried to totally set the narrative and
it it didn't work out you know Elon took
a big platform from us so okay that's
that did you think they were going to do
that no
the Democrats now within what a week of
of elon's announced potential takeover
of Twitter they have wielded the power
of the state to set up a disinformation
governance board because if if the
liberal state if liberal politicians
can't Outsource censorship to the big
tech companies they can still count on
Facebook they can still count on Google
and YouTube but they maybe can't count
on Twitter anymore to to
become the proxy by which the state
violates Americans freedom of speech
First Amendment rights and basic right
to speak and govern ourselves in a
republic if they can't rely on them
they're just going to do it themselves
which is why the Department of Family
and security has announced the setup of
the disinfo governance board
this is one of our priority areas and as
a matter of fact just a few weeks ago I
engaged with secretaries of state from
all over the country to focus our
efforts on Election security we are
building upon the great work of the
former assistant director Chris Krebs
Jenn easterly is leading of course the
cyber security and infrastructure
Security Agency in this effort we have
just established a miss and
disinformation governance board in the
Department of Homeland Security to more
effectively combat this threat not only
to election security but to our homeland
security we are disseminating
information to the secretaries of State
we are counseling them and providing
resources to ensure a better physical
security we are addressing all aspects
of election security
given of course the midterm elections
that are upon us and the fundamental
Integrity of our Democratic processes
that is at stake
already sounds spooky enough that you've
now got the federal government
determining they've got a Ministry of
truth I guess is what you'd call it this
disinformation governance board it
sounds like it could easily be used just
as a cudgel against conservatives but
look let's be as Fair as we can there is
such a thing as foreign disinformation
just look at the war in Ukraine probably
90 percent of the information coming out
of the war in Ukraine right now is
disinformation some of its Russian
disinformation some of its Ukrainian
disinformation that just goes along with
war propaganda is a big part of war and
it's a big part of statecraft so in in
principle I'm not even totally opposed
to the United States having its own kind
of propaganda Ministry every state and
throughout all of history has had a
propaganda Ministry
my issue here is is this actually going
to combat foreign disinformation or is
this just a thinly veiled excuse to
censor
half of Americans is to censor
conservatives who who disagree with the
way the liberal ruling class are
governing us
and we have our answer we don't need to
speculate about that the government's
already told us which it is it is the
latter
it is just an excuse to censor all the
conservatives because of the woman that
they picked to run this thing the
director of the board is a woman named
Nina jankowitz
who in in 2020 right before the
presidential election came out and
described the hunter Biden laptop and
all the the ugly information that it
contained about Hunter Biden and about
Joe Biden and the Biden family's
corruption and the Biden family's crimes
and and finances described it as
disinformation
so we know the hunter Biden laptop was
totally real it's not Russian
disinformation and yet this woman who's
running the disinformation board
couldn't tell that she actually went out
on a limb and she said back on the
laptop from Hell apparently Biden notes
that 50 former National Security
officials and five former CIA heads uh
believe the laptop is a Russian
influence operation and Trump says
Russia Russia Russia so she's reacting
to the presidential debate here
and she is parroting the line from Joe
Biden and from the intelligence
community that the hunter Biden laptop
wasn't legit but the hunter Biden laptop
absolutely was legit so if passed is
precedent all this woman is going to do
is wield the power of the state to
defend Democrats to attack Republicans
and to to call any
factual claim that conservatives make
Russian disinformation and try to shut
us up
now speaking of disinformation we got a
lot of disinformation coming out of the
government Joe Biden has a federal judge
nominee up newsrat chaoduri and and I
think in all of the news about Twitter
and all of the news about the economy
some of these really radical Biden
nominees are kind of going under the
radar and people aren't paying attention
you've got to pay attention Biden is
pushing through extremely radical people
This Woman's up for a district court
and she has made the claim that cops
kill innocent black men every day in
America she's made that claim in the
past this woman is up for a federal
judge if she doesn't sound particularly
unbiased or disinterested to me
Senator Kennedy Republican senator
Kennedy came out and grilled her over
this what's even more chilling than the
claim that she the completely false
claim that she made about cops killing
innocent black men is the justification
she had for lying
this is a really simple question
councilman do you believe that cops kill
unarmed black men in America every
single day you said it at Princeton
Senator I said it in my role as an
advocate oh okay you didn't mean it
Senator I said it in my role as an
advocate to make a rhetorical point so
so when you say something that's
incorrect it's okay to excuse it by
saying oh I was being an advocate what
do you believe do you personally believe
that cops kill unarmed black men every
single day in America Senator I believe
law enforcement have an important and
challenging job in this country when you
said though Council Senator I say before
you hear today that I do believe law
enforcement have a difficult and
challenging job and I also understand
the difference I just think that's an
extraordinary statement to make with no
data to back up
note none whatsoever
there's no basis for you saying that and
you knew it then and you know it now
how isn't one possibly believe that
you're going to be unbiased on the
federal bench
excellent grilling here from Senator
kennedyans it's worth pointing out the
claim was not was not even that cops
kill innocent black men every day the
claim was that cops kill unarmed black
men every day which is a different claim
and unarmed does not mean innocent and
an a killing of an unarmed man is not
always not justified sometimes it
actually can be justified
but even that claim even that broader
claim is not true she just lied
and she admitted that she lied when
Kennedy he said that statement is not
true so Ms chowduri why did you say and
she said well that was in my role as an
advocate
in your role as an advocate you you can
lie you think that gives you license to
just lie in public well that was I was
making a rhetorical point
oh so your your rhetoric is includes
lying
no you don't you don't have any right to
lie in public
well no no but I was doing a different
job yeah you don't have a right to lie
in those different public jobs well no
no I was lying then but I'm not going to
lie now she doesn't even say she's not
gonna lie now
because she's a liar and she
she I think is representing a view that
is
really common among Democrats and among
the left which is that the end justifies
the means
which is that yeah you can tell some
lies if the lies are going to get you a
good end well yeah when I was in this
job I wanted to get this political end
so I said this thing now that I'm going
to be in this judge job I'm going to say
a different thing but you know we're all
just trying to get to the same place
if
if our elected officials have no respect
for the truth then we are completely
sunk
and and
it's even broader it's even within our
whole society if our society has no
respect for the truth then we just can't
govern ourselves if we're moving from a
society that acknowledges objective
reality and objective truth to a society
that denies subjective reality and
objective truth and only only exercises
or only claims subjective truth my truth
and your truth subjective identity my my
gender identity my ex gender expression
my oppression my my my then we can't
communicate we have there has to be a
reference outside of us that we can
point to we have to be able to speak the
same language and the words that we use
to communicate need to refer to real
things outside of us in order to
communicate in order to get along
together in society if we don't have
that
all that will ensue is chaos or that
will ensue is anarchy and we're not just
talking about the hoi polloi who are
engaging in this dangerous political
game we're actually not we're talking
specifically about the elite I bet that
woman went to some of the fanciest
schools in America boy she has the
arrogance that only a top ivy league
credential can give you the way that
she's the way that she brazenly boasts
about lying the way that she's she's
just sitting there so giving such glib
answers to this senator and what she is
saying is truth doesn't matter
what is truth
what is truth no that was just my
rhetoric it's a line that Pontius Pilate
said to Jesus Christ at the passion
he says what quit asked Veritas what is
what is truth what is well there no
there is truth and if there isn't truth
then we're then we're really sunk in
self-government
but that what the libs try to do is when
they get caught in these lies or when
they get caught in a tight political
situation one of the ways that they deny
truth is they just redefine all the
words
so you've Washington state right now has
just banned the term marijuana
they haven't banned marijuana they would
never ban the Peruvian parsley up in
Washington state but they have banned
the term marijuana and they've banned
the term marijuana because apparently
the word marijuana is racist
the term marijuana itself is pejorative
and racist even though it seems simple
because it's just one word but the
reality is we are healing the wrongs
that were committed against black and
brown people around cannabis it was
negatively associated with Mexican
immigrants it was used as a racist
terminology to lock up black and brown
people
it it's because of the racism of the
word marijuana
that people who use the illicit drugs
were thrown in prison
that's what no it's because they were
committing crimes that's why it's
because that was illegal and then people
used it and they actually didn't even
really in in recent decades no one goes
to prison for simple possession they all
go to prison for dealing and for
trafficking and they usually played it
down so even to say they went to jail
for using the illegal drug that's just
not true
they went to prison for peddling poison
to young people and working for criminal
cartels no matter where they are in the
food chain and we say no the only it's
not their fault that they committed
crimes it's because of the racism of the
word marijuana okay what are we going to
call it Haitian oregano Peruvian parsley
what do you
a dude okay now in the law we're just
going to call it doobies
we're just is that is that going to
change anything no the question is
should this substance be legal or not
should we prosecute it or not one of my
least popular views is I don't see any
reason to legalize marijuana
I don't see any reason because one of my
strongest Arguments for keeping it
illegal is that the potheads who really
really are insanely pro-legalization are
almost always
extremely airheaded Libs I'm not saying
that some people on the right don't like
a little Peruvian parsley too but the
ones who make it their whole identity
the people who just clamor for it
they're protesting to legalize they're
always huge Libs and I see no reason to
give them what they want and that
especially in that case why do we why do
we need to why do we need to introduce a
new drug to the mainstream I I don't see
any reason to do it but regardless of
what you feel about it maybe you you're
the most Pro legalized pot person in the
world surely you don't think
that the political issue will be
resolved by just Banning the word
because it's racist why is it racist
well because it's a Spanish word why is
it a Spanish word because it comes from
Latin America that's why it's not it's
not like marijuana was discovered in uh
I don't know Boston right it's not it's
not as though this it was discovered in
Liverpool no it comes that's the area
that it comes from
and it's not but the word racist gets
you off the hook for anything
the word race if you just invoke racism
no matter how tenuous the argument is
that will get you off the hook for
anything that is the magical word it's
how the libs have been able to destroy
our drug laws our Criminal Justice
System our immigration system uh it's
it's been how they've been able to are
are equal protection it's how they've
been able to destroy even fairness and
hiring and college admissions they say
that if you don't support racial quotas
for certain groups and if you don't
support uh giving a boost to certain
people on the color of their race then
you're a racist so they just use the
word racist and they banded about and
they get whatever they want because
they've capped conservatives into
submission well there's one area
speaking of using racism as a cudgel and
speaking of Latin America there's one
area where
that that leftist political agenda is
apparently on hold for now that is down
at our Southern border with regard to
title 42 title 42
was a way that the Trump Administration
was able to to curtail to some degree
illegal immigration to America because
they said look if you're going to lock
down all the American citizens because
of this pandemic then surely you've got
to put some more restrictions on the
southern border right it's insane you're
telling me that an American citizen
can't go down the street to 7-Eleven
without wearing a hazmat suit but you're
just going to let millions of foreign
Nationals unvetted pour over our border
without any question no you can't do
that and so this was in place the Biden
Administration still wants to keep
American citizens locked down but they
they want to keep that border open
they're moving to keep that border open
they're trying to lift title 42 and a
federal judge just shot them down
federal judge in Louisiana has issued a
temporary restraining order against the
Biden Administration
forbidding it from moving ahead with its
plan to end title 42 this is Judge
Robert Summerhays of the Western
District of Louisiana
he he issued this just yesterday
but unfortunately it's just temporary
the odds that this actually lasts
pretty low
because the libs have all the power here
okay they've got they've got the
administrative State they've got the
elected government they've got the media
they've got
they've got everything okay and so there
is not going to be any fix to the
southern border into our immigration
system until conservatives grab hold of
more institutions of power it's not
going to be enough to win back the house
that's not going to do it it's not going
to be enough to win back the Senate
that's not going to do it it's not going
to be enough to win back the presidency
we had Unified Government under Donald
Trump illegal immigration dropped
dramatically right when Trump was
elected
and we had Unified Government for the
Republicans but then very quickly it
became clear that that wasn't enough and
so that wasn't actually going to lead to
the construction of full border wall or
to a limitation of immigration and so
then you saw the immigration numbers pop
right back up
we can argue it all day we can write
long essays we can have big robust
debates but unless conservatives go in
and actually capture those institutions
of government
and media
and Corporation
and finance and education and all of
them unless we capture those
institutions and wield that political
power it's not going to matter you can
make the most eloquent argument in the
world it's not going to do Jack diddly
the libs are flaunting
their political power and they're doing
it through their hypocrisy a lot of
times conservatives point out liberal
hypocrisy whether it's in education
whether it's covid especially we point
out the hypocrisy and we say if the shoe
were on the other foot can you imagine
if the roles were reversed look at this
outrageous hypocrisy
we're not telling the libs anything they
don't know
they know about the hypocrisy
they're they're flaunting
it is the proof that they have almost
absolute power in the United States the
fact that they can behave in a
hypocritical way the fact that fauci
doesn't wear his mask
but he forces all of you to wear your
masks
that is a feature not a not a bug of the
system that is that is a way to say I'm
in charge what are you going to do about
it Punk Pete Buda judge is doing this
right now Pete butterjudge just went on
uh Fox News he was asked about the White
House correspondent association dinner
and he said hold on
uh Brett Bear who was asking him the
question said hold on
all you Democrats are arguing that we
need to reinstate the airplane mask
mandate we need to reinstate the public
transportation mandate and yet you're
going to cram hundreds of Libs into a
tiny little Ballroom in Washington DC
and none of you are going to be wearing
your masks no mandate for the liberal
Elites in DC
lots of mandates for all the other
Americans what gives here's Pete's
answer
if you're sitting at home you just told
me you're going to the White House
Correspondence Dinner the president's
going to the White House Correspondence
Dinner you're not mandated to wear a
mask there but the administration at the
same time is fighting a lawsuit to
mandate people on Planes Trains and
honorable or trains and buses to
wear masks so like if you're sitting at
home there's a disconnect here well I
think most of us understand the
difference between a hotel ballroom and
an airplane and again a lot of this is
about what authorities the CDC has
bootage Edge accidentally told on
himself that's what that's what the
Liberals have been doing so often
because what he's insinuating here is
but most America listen
come on guys come on I'm reasonable
people to judge hi I'm reasonable
radical people to judge
we know the difference the scientific
and medical difference between an
airplane and a ballroom he's insinuating
that the airplane is much more dangerous
for spreading covid than a ballroom or a
hotel or a restaurant and that's just
not true it's just not borne out by the
data that has never been true airplanes
have been some of the safest places
during the entirety of the covid
pandemic
part of this is because airplanes are
getting fresh air constantly people
expected airplanes to be big hot spots
for spreading the virus and they just
never were
whereas
large Gatherings of people indoors
without fresh air constantly circulating
those have been big areas hotel
ballrooms have been big areas of spread
for coven
so yeah here's the difference you sh if
you're going to wear the mask at all you
should wear it in the hotel Ballroom you
shouldn't wear it on the airplane but
the real difference between the airplane
and the hotel Ballroom is that in the
White House correspondence association
dinner Ballroom you're going to have a
bunch of liberal DC Elites and in the
airplane you're just going to have
ordinary Americans
and the ordinary Americans have to
follow extra rules then and different
rules than the DC Elites
I think most Americans can tell the
difference yeah right they can tell the
difference
we can and he's flaunting it
well the difference is I get to do
whatever the hell I want and you don't
because you're a dirty filthy peasant
and I don't want your germs but I don't
have germs because I'm I'm people to
judge and we can all agree that I'm a
clean uh beautiful wonderful person and
you're not you're filth you're
disgusting cover up your face you dirty
rat peasant that's that's what he's
saying
and and what are we going to do about it
what are we going to do the conservative
response has been hey
do what you want if New York wants a
mask mandate that's fine and if you by
the way if you have to Country if you
want to wear masks in public that's fine
you do you live and Let Live that's fine
by me just don't make me do it just
leave me alone
the one thing I will say for having
people voluntarily wear masks on
airplanes is it does tell you with 100
certainty exactly who the libs are on
your flight which can be very helpful
but we need to go further we need to say
no it's it's actually disordered to have
a society full of Banditos it's not good
we don't we're not Saudi Arabia we don't
think people should cover up their faces
all the time in public so no actually
outside of extremely rare circumstances
don't do that just don't you should be
actively discouraged from doing that the
Oklahoma governor on a sort of
completely different issue but same
political principle the Oklahoma
governor just outlawed the non-binary
sex option
on birth certificates some legislatures
I guess have been suggesting a third
option on birth certificates whether you
put this down when the baby is born or
or later on they can change it the text
of the law requires the biological sex
designation on a birth certificate to be
either male or female it prohibits
people from changing the sex on their
birth certificates that's very important
that's what we have to do we need to go
in and say no we need to go in and set
the rules I think I'm now I'm remember I
think it might have been oron McIntyre
it was somebody though somebody on
Twitter or somewhere who made this point
that the party that does something is
always going to beat the party that just
wants to be left alone so what is it
what is it that we want to do I'm glad
Elon Musk freed up our speech a little
bit for now at least good I'm glad we've
got that Free Speech now so what are we
going to do with it what are we going to
say what standards are we going to set
I'm Michael Knowles this the Michael
Knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Knowles show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vidovsky
editor and Associate producer Danny
D'Amico associate producer Justine
Turley audio mixer Mike coromina and
hair and makeup by Cherokee heart
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the Matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture Faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show